in this video I'm going to show you how
to use Photoshop files in After Effects
the right way
[Music]
hey there my name is Cameron with motion
science and in this video I'm going to
show you how to use Photoshop files in
After Effects now a lot of people seem
to think that it's a complicated process
and will instead use PNG or Tiff files
but I'm here to show you that it's
actually better to use Photoshop and
it's really simple let me show you how
all right to start off here we are in
Photoshop and we've got three text
layers new music and wave and then we
have a background layer as well and what
I see happen a lot of times is layers
will be turned off and we will go to
file export quick export as PNG and we
save out individual PNG files like the
background and then we turn that off and
we go to the wave effect same thing file
export quick export as PNG we'll do
music and we'll do new then over in
After Effects we have to select all four
PNG files and then once they're imported
we can drag them onto our timeline and
we can see we we've got the background
wave
music and new now the problem with this
is first off we have to rearrange the
layers we have to get the composition
set to the right size to match the PNG
file and so on and so forth and if we
want to change something we have to go
back into Photoshop find that layer and
change things re-export it and bring it
back in After Effects now the smarter
way to work is not to bring in PNG files
it is to bring in a Photoshop file so
how we do that we double click inner
project window to import we find our PSD
file and we go to import as composition
retain layer sizes click open then we
get prompted with this window I
typically leave merge layer Styles into
footage you can use editable layer
Styles if you want to change effects
click OK and now it's really cool is we
have a folder with our layers but we
also have a composition here and if I
double click this composition it is set
to the correct size of the Photoshop
file so it's already set to the correct
aspect ratio to the correct pixel
dimensions and then we have our layers
here all laid out in a nice orderly
fashion now what's really cool about
this is let's say I want to change this
word new I can change this in one of
three ways the first way is to go up to
edit
edit original
the second way is to right click go to
open
edit original or the easiest way for me
on a Mac is to hit command e
and it opens up the Photoshop file in
Photoshop and now what I can do is I can
change this to let's say the word synth
I can hit command s to save I can jump
back in After Effects and it's
automatically updated with my new title
on the same layer right I can do this
with any layer I can go into music if I
want to change that let's change it to
the word track save jump back into After
Effects you can see it's automatically
updated we can do this also with things
like backgrounds if for some reason we
wanted to change this background let's
say we add a hue saturation let's change
it to a green something like this click
OK Now command s to save jump back into
After Effects you can see it's
automatically updated and that my
friends is how I work with Photoshop
files inside of After Effects versus
using PNG or tip files I hope that you
really enjoy this lesson as much as I
loved teaching it so please let me know
if you have any questions in the
comments below I'd love to answer them
for you hit that like button if you
enjoyed this video and please subscribe
to this channel it helps other people
find this channel as well if you're
looking to upgrade your design skill set
master the art of style and execute like
a pro I have a course called stylecraft
that you can check out at
motionscience.tv you can also learn more
about this course by clicking the link
in the description below as always
thanks for watching my name is Cameron
and this is motion science
[Music]
foreign